let's go to the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 starting with Tim Tim back in
January I guess was the last time we
heard from you and you were you were
pretty angry from what I have in my
notes when we spoke back in January is
does that sound right I don't know if I
was angry I know we're talking back and
forth about health care and how it would
be what the hell was gonna be paid for
with 52 trillion dollars right yeah per
year I don't know how you know what even
the you know the statistics you provided
me I don't even know how it would still
be paid for but you know regardless I
was seeing that you were doing a bunch
of live streams on the impeachment
hearings and I wanted to see you know
what's your takeaway from what's going
on and what do you think the outcome for
Democrats would be positive or negative
well I've got a big story coming out on
this because on the one hand you've had
you know there have been some people
testifying who have not really made a
big impact but certainly Gordon Sunland
has made it clear that everybody knew
what was going on Rudy Giuliani knew
Mike Pompeo knew Mike Pence knew Donald
Trump knew everybody knew about the
extortion bribery quid pro quo that
should be extremely damaging lieutenant
colonel Alexander VIN Minh had very
devastating testimony but I'll be honest
with you Tim I said if Democrats can't
turn this into something it will be very
embarrassing because they're
monopolizing dozens of hours of TV time
across all networks it is even in its
most salacious moments you've still got
to pay really close attention for hours
at a time to understand what went on and
I don't know if Democrats are going to
be able to turn this into something and
add on what you just said I think it's
also costing the taxpayers tens of
thousands of dollars to hold these
circus hearings to begin with
and when it comes to actually breaking a
law there hasn't been you know
substantial evidence of anything that's
why even you said they don't have
anything well no I never I certainly
never said they don't have anything what
I said is that first so there's a couple
different things these are not criminal
proceedings
impeachment proceedings are not criminal
so we can talk about criminal but that's
actually that that's a totally separate
issue altogether it relates to the
Justice Department two different things
we don't want to mix them up but I
certainly severed never say they don't
have anything what I said is as
devastating as what they have is I still
am unsure I mean listen I just I don't
see impeachment happening hopefully this
will fire people up enough that they
vote Trump out in November of 2020
that's that's for me the most likely
positive outcome that I can imagine well
isn't the impeachment hearings in and of
itself high crimes and misdemeanors
according to you know based on the
president's actions so don't understand
there are high crimes high crimes means
the person doing it not what the crime
is so there's a lot of misunderstanding
about what what that even means but
we're talking again you can be impeached
not because you committed a felony for
example but because what you did
abdicated the the morality you abdicated
the role of the president you gave up
sovereignty to a foreign country there
are things that may or may not be crimes
that are ever prosecuted they can still
be impeachable so it's important not to
confuse criminal proceedings with
impeachment proceedings this also
relates to due process a lot of the
conversation is happening about due
process seems to misunderstand what kind
of a proceeding this is but it sounds
like you're watching the streams and and
that's good at least people are paying
attention yeah I mean I've been
following this pretty closely and you
know I followed this regularly and I see
that there doesn t there just seems to
be hearsay from what I see on my end
from secondhand conversations no
sunlight or his own conversations Gordon
Sunland gave all firsthand testimony so
I don't know maybe you're defining
here's here's that's a Republican
talking point that there's a motive that
people say well hold on that's a
different question that you first said
that there's only hearsay I pointed out
that there isn't and now you say well
who cares no no from the first two
proceedings that we had there was all
hearsay now we're having it from
directly from the horse's mouth but that
still not giving Democrats anything to
work with
as you said previously no whether they
have a word I'm agreeing with you in a
sense but the reason that they may not
have anything to work with
is that you have 62% of Trumpets who
said I don't care what he ever does I
will never abandon him and when you're
dealing with people like that he could
shoot someone on Fifth Avenue and it
wouldn't matter so I think it's
important to distinguish between there
is nothing versus Republicans won't care
and that's the situation that we have
Tim well the transcript is out so the
entire transcript of the call is out the
American people have read the transcript
I haven't seen Don granese who released
the full transcript come per week the
full transcript no he that was a 30
minute 400 Trump released a transcript
that was about six or seven minutes of a
30-minute phone call unless it happened
in the last five minutes Trump has not
released the full transcript see this is
the problem people's ears would be
confused there was an old transport was
never everything so so you first you now
you said the full transcript has been
released it hasn't and now you're just
saying there is nothing you're you're
doing circular arguments none of them
based on fact every fact you assert is
wrong and then you move on to something
else too the fact is there's no
substantial evidence for impeachment and
you know this and you know what in your
bones like it's not gonna happen
and it's gonna end up Obama if this were
he would have been impeached who knows
when all right Tim we're gonna let you
go Tim I mean I guess that's just what a
Republican sounds like or at least
someone who's committed to the narrative
that Trump Trump can do no wrong I mean
listen I'll agree with you this might
not lead to anything but to say there's
no evidence to say Trump really
everything that the guy said I think
almost everything has been demonstrably
debunked